جمال اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه نستضيف فيها دائما المحلل
العسكري لء فايز الدويري اهلا بك معنا
سنتابع مع اللواء فايز الدويري اب الدويري
ابرز التطورات لكن قبل ذلك نذهب الى سلام
خضر التي تتابع عبر الخريطه التفاعليه
ابرز المستجدات العسكريه شكرا عبد السلام
سنبدا من جنوب قطاع غزه المنطقه الاكثر
احتداماً مر طبعا منذ الثاني من ديسمبر
الماضي الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال يقاتل في
جنوب القطاع في خان يونس هي واحده من
البؤر الاساسيه ولكن اليوم ايضا توسع
القتال ليشمل منطقه الزنه مره جديده وا
اضافه الى خانيونس طبعا الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول انه ان عملياته في قطاع غزه في
الجنوب تسير ببطء لكنها تسير على عده
جبهات بمعنى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يهاجم
اكثر من منطقه في لحظه واحده وفي مكان
واحد اليوم شهدنا استهدافات لكتائب القسام
وفصائل المقاومه
لمجموعات اسرائيليه في الزنه وفي خانيونس
وهناك استمرار في منطقه خزاعه لسياسه
التدمير العالي خزاعه تتعرض لضربات قاسيه
جدا الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما يهاجم خزاعه
كانت برفقته جرافات ب عندما يقصف منطقه
يقوم
بازاله الحطام المكان الذي قصفه يشتبه بان
المقاومين يستخدمون الحطام كغطاء يتم
مهاجمه القوات الاسرائيليه من خلاله او
حتى يزرعون العبوات والجيش الاسرائيلي قال
انه يعاني من هذه المشكله مشكله العبوات
التي تستهدف الافراد وتستهدف ايضا الاليات
في وسط قطاع غزه تبقى المعارك مستمره في
النصيرات وفي البريج ولكن اليوم المغازي
باتت ايضا تحت
الاستهداف العالي بمعنى المكثف هناك طبعا
هجمات ومحاوله توغل في المغازي وما زالت
القوات الاسرائيليه تحاول الدخول والسيطره
بالكامل على مخيم البريج العمليات
التي ينفذ الجيش الاسرائيلي في وسط القطاع
لا تقتصر ف فقط على مناطق العمليات اليوم
شهدنا استهدافات مكثفه للشريط الحدودي مع
غزه هناك استهدافات كانت بقصف مكثف قصف
مدفعي مكثف وفي بعض الاحيان شنت غارات على
هذه المنطقه كنا نقول باننا نشتبه بان
الاسرائيليين يقومون بعمليه قصف تحاشيا
لهجمات من الخ خلف اثناء تقدم الياته
ويبدو ان هذا الذي يحدث مع الاسرائيليين
يتكرر مره اخرى تكون القوات تهاجم من
الغرب فيلتف المقاومون وتصبح الهجمات من
الخلف بالتزامن مع الجهه التي يتم منها
الهجوم نقطه اخيره الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اليوم ايضا عاد وقصف المناطق
الشماليه الشجاعيه وجباليا بشكل خاص ولكن
هذا كله يجب ان نقرا فيه خاصه مع
تنامي المشاكل السياسيه والاشتباك السياسي
داخل مجلس الحرب الاس ولابد ان لكل عمل
ميداني انعكاساته السياسيه شكرا جزيلا لك
سلام خضر سياده اللواء هناك تحشيد عسكري
كبير لكن في المقابل هناك استهداف قنص
واحيانا استهداف لاليات عسكريه عدد الجنود
الاسرائيليين الذين اصيبوا في العمليات
العسكريه و اصاباتهم خطيره ارتفع بشكل
كبير هذا ما يسمح به النشر حتى الان كيف
تقرا تطور المشهد الميداني الان انت اشرت
الى كثافه
القوات اذا تحدثنا عن منطقه الو للشمال
يوجد الان اربعه الويه وهذه المنطقه على
اعتبار كانت في طريقها للتحول للمرحله
الثالثه اللي هو عمليه الانسحاب لكن عادت
وحاولت ان تتمسك في بعض المناطق فيوجد
اربعه الويه اي فرقه زائد في منطقه الشمال
اذا ذهبنا الى الوسط توجد الفرقه
36 مدعومه بلوائي مظليين مدعومه بكتائب
نخبه اي بما يعادل فرقتين
ناقص اذا ذهبنا الى الجنوب تم زياده العدد
بالامس كانت سبعه الويه في هذا اليوم
اصبحت ث اول امس كانت سبعه امبارح تم بدفع
بلواء
ثامن
وبالتالي عن عندما تتحدث عن المنطقه
الجنوبيه هذه
وثمانيه الويه ما يقارب ثلاثه فرق يعني
كثافه في العدد الاليات والجنود والافراد
لكن رغم كل ذلك الانجازات ليست بمستوى
القوه ورغم فارق القدرات لكن ما هو الذي
يساعد المقاومه على الاستمرار في القتال
وايقاع الخسائر هي طريقه اداره المعركه
الدفاعيه لانه مج
في الانفاق يخرجوا من نقاط معينه في اوقات
معينه لاحظ منطقه عبسان الجديده بنسله
عبسان الكبيره الى الى مشارف خزاعه يعني
من جنوب الزنه الى شمال خزاعه ها المنطقه
لم يجري فيها لم تدخلها القوات جيش
الاحتلال حت هذه اللحظه لا بل اجبروا بعد
ان تقدموا في منطقه خزاعه اجبروا على
التراجع ودفعوا لواء من الامام الى الخلف
كذلك اذا ذهبنا الى شمال الزنه في منطقه
القراره تم تجاوزها منذ فتره طويله في منذ
يوم امس هناك لم تحدد حجم القوه لكن تهاجم
من ثلاثه
اتجاهات من الشرق من الجنوب ومن الغرب
وكذلك في المغرا في
شمال اذا دعني اقول هناك تغيير في اداره
المعركه من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي في
المنطقه الوسطى تحت ديدا يستخدم الان ما
يطلق عليها العمليات المشتركه لماذا لانه
الان يوظف بها سلاح الجو القوات البريه
والقوات البحريه وهو يحاول ان يتبنى
المقاربه الامريكيه في حربها على داعش وفي
العراق من حيث تطويق البلدات الصغيره من
كافه الجوانب والدخول المتدرج للانهاء كل
شيء فيه هل هل لهذا التطور الميداني
عموما يعني هناك بقاء ل القوات
الاسرائيليه لفتره طويله في بعض المناطق
تحدثت انت عن المغرا البريج المغازي ما
زالت التي تقصف منذ ثلاثه اشهر ما زالت في
في قلب الاحداث خزاعه ايضا لم لم يتم
اختراق المناطق الجنوبيه كما يريد جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فهل هناك تفسير
لكثافه القصف في ظل زياره انتوني بلينكن
في في ظل الحديث عن ما بعد الحرب في ظل
الحديث عن خلافات في مجلس الحرب الذي الان
بدات الاشارات بانه لن يستمر يا سيد يعني
الان هذه مشكله معذره مجلس الحرب
بسبب اختلاف الخلفيات الايديولوجيه من
اليمين المتطرف الى الى يمين اليمين الى
غير ذلك بينما حتى كذلك في الجانب
الامريكي الواقع الميداني يقول عكس ما
يتحدث هم تقديراتهم هم شمال خان يونس
يحتاج الى
شهر الجزء شمال مدينه خان يونس هذه القطعه
الصغيره تحتاج الى شهر جنوب خان يونس مع
المناطق الاخرى هذه تحتاج الى عده اشهر
يعني حسب وجهه نظرهم عام 2024 كامل يا دوب
الحرب تنتهي لكن السؤال هل هذا الجيش قادر
على الزج بهذا الحجم من القوه ه هذا
الاطار الزمني هل الامريكيين يوافقوا
ستبدا الانتخابات الامريكيه قريبا
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان ان يضحي الحزب
الديمقراطي بمستقبله السياسي من اجل انقاذ
رقبه نتنياهو هيئه البث الاسرائيليه تح
حدثت قبل قليل عن ان هناك حديث بان مجلس
الحرب لن يستمر وقبل ذلك كان حديث عن
انشاء من قبل رئيس الاركان اركان الجيش
انشا لجنه للتحقيق في احداث السابع من
اكتوبر الخلافات هذه تاثيرها على الميدان
يا سيدي هي نابعه يعني نتنياهو حكم 16 سنه
لكن هذه السنه الاخيره هي الاسوا في حكمه
رغم انه كل حكمه سيء هذه الاسو بالنسبه له
على الصعيد الشخصي لانه رهن رقبته ل ب
بنفير وسموت وبالتالي هؤلاء جاؤوا من خارج
البيت السياسي يعني لا يعرفوا باليه
التعامل يوجهوا اهانات الى الى رئيس
الاركان وبالتالي هناك انتقادات حاده هذا
الامر انعكس على اداء الجي جيش الاحتلال
وبالتالي
تلاحظ الزج بحجم قوه يقاتل به ثلاثه دول
ولكنه فشل عن هو نجح في التدمير لكنه فشل
في انقاذ رهينه واحده
ولن يستطيع الاستمرار كما يقولوا وبالتالي
التصدع وارد جدا لانه الان مقسومين اثنين
اثنين وبالتالي س الطرف الاخر قد ينسحب في
اي لحظه لانه لا يريد ان يغرق ه في مركب
نتنياهو هل هذا مرتبط ايضا بتحقيق نتائج
على الارض الحديث عن القضاء على حركه حماس
لم يتحقق بل ان الجانب الامريكي يعيد
تقييمه للوضع بان حركه حماس باقيه وان
لديها قوه عسكريه موجوده وينبغي الاعتراف
بان هذا واقع يجب تقبله هذا الجانب
الامريكي وفي ظل زياره انتري بلينكن
للمنطقه الحديث هذا مجلس الحرب ماذا لو
بالفعل تم تفكيكه ولم يستمر كيف يكون
اتوقع الان ندخل في يعني هل هو مهم مجلس
الحرب لاداره المعارك هم عاده ما ينشئوا
حكومه طوارئ في في اي في كل الحروب
السابقه انشا حكومه طوارئ وكانت حزب العمل
والليكود هم الاقطاب الرئيسيه يتم جمعهم
وا من اجل الوحده واللحمه الوطنيه والوقوف
خلف الجيش الان طال امد
الحرب لم يتم انقاذ اي رهينه
الاسقاطات الكل اذا اصبح مقتنعا ان
نتنياهو يدير الحرب لمصلحه شخصيه وفي هذا
اليوم وجهت رساله له من قبل
اي القسام وكانت الرساله واضحه انه هذا
كانه يعاني من عقده نفسيه لانه اخوه قتل
في عم عمليه تحرير اسر فهو لا يسال عن
اسراكم وبالتالي لا لا تصدقوه الان هذا
كله سينعكس عن مجلس الحرب لانه كل واحد
منهم ياتي من خلفيه سياسيه مختلفه وكل
واحد فيهم
له له مطامح ان ان يحصل الى كرسي الرئاسه
فبالتالي لا يمكن ان يبقوا في مركب على
وشك الغرض ام اذا اردنا ان نفهم الان في
ظل هذه التطورات خلافات سياسيه كبيره مجلس
الحرب بحسب هيئه البث الاسرا قد لا يستمر
المقاومه ما الذي ستقوم به في هذه الفتره
تكثر اكثر من الاستهدافات وبالتالي يزيد
ذلك من تاثيرها يا سيدي الان
اليه المقاربه المقاربه القتاليه هي الان
في حاله اشتباك والاشتباك ياخذ عده ابعاد
معركه المعركه التصادميه وال المعركه
الصفريه وال العمل خلف خطوط العدو
وبالتالي هذا هذا ح حاله اشتباك لكن لنفرض
ان هذه القوات تراجعت الى المناطق الخلفيه
فالمقاومة خان يونس المشتعله منذ فتره
طويله هل تعتقد بان هناك يعني تقييمك لوضع
خان يونس من حيث توقيت العمليه استمرار
العمليه الزخم الذي يقوم به الجيش هناك
ومدى تاثيره في الايام المقبله الان مشكله
هذه المنطقه منطقه واسعه لا تقاس بمدينه
غزه من شرق شارع صلاح الدين شرق مدينه خان
يونس منطقه واسعه منطقه بني سهيله عبسان
عبسان الكبرى من زنيه اذا هذه المنطقه
واسعه وحتى وفيها شبكه انفاق وفيها
اي نخبه فصائل المقاومه مضاف الى لواء خان
يونس وبالتالي تعتبر كانها الكتله الضاربه
في في كتائب القسام وبقيه الفصائل ويبدو
ان فيها شبكه انفاق طبيعه الارض ساعدت على
انشاها وقد تكون اكثر تعقيدا واكثر فاعليه
من الانفاق داخل مدينه غزه هناك انفاق
داخل المدينه كان على كان تحديد في ايجاد
المخارج والفتحات انت هنا تتحدث عن مسافات
بينيه انظر الى الخارطه قد يكون لديك كل
50 متر او 100 متر فتحه نفق هذا ماذا يعني
يعني ان هذه الشبكه شبكه عنكبوتيه معقده
وهذا الذي يمنع الان هذه القوات ان تدخل
تحديدا في بنسي و عبسان و عبسان الكبيره
ام بالحديث مع وائل الدحدوح
كان شبه ما حدث ما يحدث الان في خانيونس
بتجارب سابقه استهداف المستشفيات في في
الشمال هل يخشى على خان يونس في هذا
التوقيت مؤكد مؤكد لانه هو هو المقاربه هي
التدمير يعني وزير التراث ماذا ي قال هذا
اليوم يجب ان نجد طريقه طريقه اكثر ايلاما
من القتل يعني يعتبر ان اهل غزه تعودوا
على القتل فهو بده طريقه اكثر ايلاما واحد
يفكر بهذه العقليه اذا هو يتمنى
ان لا يبقي غرفه واحده على ارض غزه شكرا
جزيلا لك اللواء فائز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي على كل ما تفضلت به
شكرا وص بطبيعه الحال ل الزميله سلام خضر
بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه النافذه
العسكريه الخاصه بحرب اسرائيل على قطاع
غزه نعود مره اخرى الى غرفه الاخبار